I would not use divine in in the way
that most theists use the word I think
if we if we want to say the universe is
divine because it has the laws of nature
that gives rise to sentient beings that
then become aware of the universe having
those laws of nature that give rise to
sentience is that a thumbs up if that's
a thought that if that's divinity then
I'm a believer okay so okay boom what's
up everyone welcome to simulation I'm
your host I'll sake on we are on site at
TV Santa Barbara in the beautiful Santa
Barbara California we are now going to
be talking about skepticism around
spirituality and much more we have dr.
Michael Shermer joining us um hello sir
thank you for coming nice to be back on
the show returning champion returning
server so excited and for those that
don't know Michael schirmer's background
he's founder of the skeptic Society with
55,000 members editor-in-chief of its
magazine skeptic a two hundred fourteen
time monthly columnist for Scientific
American from 2001 2019 presidential
fellow at Chapman University teaching
skepticism 101 and a 15-time author were
several New York Times bestsellers most
recently into moral arc and heavens on
earth you can find the links in the bio
below Michael Shermer comma sloth
skeptic comm check out the links in the
bio Michael let's start things off by
asking you about skepticism around
spirituality because we have this we
have this beautiful planet that sustains
us that gives us the air we need to
breathe it gives us the water we need to
drink the food we knew need for
nourishment so many people talk about a
spiritual connection to the planet that
sustains us and how we have in a sense
we have disconnected from that spiritual
recognition and that's why we have so
many of the issues we have in our
society how do you feel about that mmm
let's unpack that a little bit first of
all most of the resources we have from
the planet are not given to us we have
to extract them through labor so I mean
air and water okay that's true we don't
have to do much for that other than
breathe deep and
dip into the the the lake or river or
desalinate the ocean okay so but even
that desalination requires some effort
everything else is pretty much resources
depend on brain power that is using our
intellect to solve certain problems to
carve out a niche of order in the teeth
of the second law of thermodynamics the
entropy of the world just running down
so it's not like we get a gift and we
just sit and take it we actually have to
do something and most of what life is
about I mean the purpose of life is is
extra P it's to push back against
entropy other than that you're you're
dead if you don't do that so right there
I'd say the relationship between us and
nature is a very interactive one it's
not like we just receive a gift at all I
think what you're after is more like
gratitude that that we have this
capacity to do this and that we have the
resources of a planet that enables us to
thrive and flourish for sure I would say
gratitude is the right attitude that we
should have if but on the other end
that's how evolution works if we evolved
on Mars you know we we would have a
different set of physical
characteristics to live in that kind of
environment or some other planet or moon
or something like that that's about to
be tested we're about to find out what
it's like to be in multiplanetary
species and what it takes to survive and
thrive so but I mean I see where you're
coming from I understand the Gaia
hypothesis and James Lovelock's metaphor
which may be more than a metaphor he
thinks it's more than a metaphor the
planet is actually alive how do you feel
about well I think that depends on how
you define life I mean the planet is not
a living organism in the same way that
organisms are that reproduce
for example the planet doesn't make baby
earths that's so it's not doing that
it's an interesting one yeah but we do
kind of see it breathing with
polarizing yeah breathing in in that in
that sense it's cyclic all processes
energy yeah for sure
but so it this these kinds of things all
turn on linguistic definitions you know
what do you mean by spirituality what do
you mean by life that kind of thing so
if we don't get lost in the semantics
and we stay with this kind of what we
feel every time that we breathe how the
planet sustains us what about that
feeling yeah it's a feeling that's right
it's okay again if you want to remove it
from kind of a scientific mechanical
analysis and just say you know
spiritually or emotionally you know
should we feel gratitude yes absolutely
I'm grateful you know for every day that
I'm alive I'm an atheist so I don't
think there's an afterlife if I'm wrong
and it turns out there is okay well I'll
deal with that when I get there I guess
but in the meantime I'm just you know
just feel fortunate that we you know
have had this little niche of order for
some period of few decades and that
that's good enough another way to look
at it is that the same thing with your
body you have your something's happening
in your liver that inevitably you're
gonna have issues within the potential
your kidneys with your stomach with
other lungs other areas of your body and
then you'll even die similarly with our
planet if we are going extremely over
the edge with the amount that we're
extracting from the planet the way that
we're polluting the ecosystems that we
live in then the planet sees that as a
part of its organ to function
dysfunctionality and then works its way
to potentially even even spray us off
like a like a bad case of it make
insects on it yeah I think the
environmental movement should take more
credit than it does for that awareness
and not just awareness but actually
let's do something about it now I
understand most nonprofits because I run
one kind of have a strong impulse to cry
gloom and doom because that's what
brings in more donations
if you know if you just say things are
great and getting better people feel
like well then I'm gonna find some other
cause to donate to where things are bad
getting worse in fact I think the
environmental movement has had a huge
positive effect since the 60s and 70s of
cleaning up air cleaning up the air in
most major cities Los Angeles you know
just south of us here I mean this is
where I was born and raised in the 60s
when I was a kid out playing baseball
and in the 80s when I was a cyclist you
you had to be done by like 10:00 or
11:00 in the morning for say May to
September October the air was so bad you
know that's just not an issue anymore
why because we cleaned up the air most
of the major waterways in America have
been cleaned up that's thanks to the
environmental movement
you know the whole scare about
overpopulation that's a non-issue now
really I mean it's it's the way we're
going under population is going to be a
problem in in a century or two so I mean
and that's because people have decided
okay we're gonna do something about this
and other pressures like the more
economically prosperous families are
particularly women the less likely they
are to have more kids so family size
decreases with economic prosperity and
political freedom for women for example
so all those things I think things are
good and getting better and so all the
scare stories you see on the news about
environmental problems those have to be
put into context you know follow the
trend lines not just the headlines yeah
and there are definitely as a massive
shift towards cleaning up some of the
ecosystems that we've been polluting
that type of stuff simultaneously we we
do see pretty in immediate miss that we
have with staying vigilant with the way
that certain businesses are maybe
signaling that a things are totally good
meanwhile we continue a process of
extracting plundering the earth selling
you things that you may not even really
need
that you're just buying to impress
people that you don't even like and then
furthermore is the cyclical process of
that conspicuous consumption and the
disconnection that people have the
filling potentially some of the
fragmentations that they have with their
own divine understanding of who they are
what their purpose is with filling those
voids with temporary satiation and
pleasure that aren't even I'm not so
worried about that because that's so
subjective there's nothing wrong with
wanting you know cell phones for example
I see you have an iPhone so computer
seems like it's all great and and you
could counter and go well but we're
using these rare earth metals and
they're called rare earth for a reason
because they're rare and China has most
of them and you know this is fraught
with you know political implications and
tariffs and you know what do we need
these for anyway well you don't need
them you know I I'm old enough to
remember a life without any of that
stuff right and life was fine then it's
I feel it's richer and better now but
that's that's kind of a subjective thing
I'm more worried about more immediate
climate denial for example on the part
of Republicans the this political issue
that you know climate science is a
liberal conspiracy against big business
or whatever we that's a more immediate
problem that has to be countered which
is I'm working on that we're working
lots of us are working on that but you
know again if a Democrat gets back into
into the White House in 2020 or 2024
those trends will be reversed again the
long-term trend is good terms in the
environment immediate problems I think
we do need to be addressed
you know climb I still worry about nukes
a bit not a bit but it's probably even
more of a threat I think and then
climate change even though things are
much better regarding nuclear weapon
knowledge and synthetic biology yeah
yeah I'll bet you know they're on the
list right they're all there but at the
same time all of the these pressing
fields of exponential technology in the
geopolitical
difficulties that we're facing dealing
with them the these these things stem
from the same place let's see if we
agree on this do we do you feel as
though the issues that we have in our
society with denying the changing
climate and all these things that you
listed as well that or maybe the way
that we're just not consciously
plundering the earth and selling things
people that maybe they don't want or
need maybe that that all stems from the
same place which is our art lack of
understanding of the ecosystem that we
are all born from this planet mmm what
do you tell you I don't know that it
feels a little Oh seems a little
California holistic from the sixties
people I think generally most people
want more stuff and that if you tell
them well you don't really need a
McMansion to impress the the neighbors
or whatever I don't know it feels that
feels a little parental to me you know
that some elitist telling the masses you
don't really need all these things you
know because life is can be can be just
as well lived and happy and satisfying
without any of that extra stuff you know
meanwhile the elitist have all their
stuff you know the Al Gore's fly in
private jets or whatever it's like or
it's like us telling China and India you
know you can't have an industrial
revolution because look what we did you
know and their attitude as well [ __ ] off
you know we're gonna you had it and we
want it and I understand that that you
know so I think instead of thinking like
that like let's see where we can cut
back and curtail things down let's think
of it as problems to be solved and keep
going forward and let people do whatever
they want and it's continue to solve the
problem so for example
karemera I use this with you and last
time we talked but the line we will
never run out of oil this is never gonna
happen and that sounds insane because
it's a finite planet at some point you
would pull out the last barrel of oil no
no one's ever gonna pull out the last
barrel of oil because it'll be too damn
expensive at some point when the supply
really does start to dry up and we
really do hit peak oil whenever that is
the price will just become too high and
we'll have to find alternatives so
electric cars instead of instead of
internal combustion engine cars that's
already happening you know by 2050 I
don't think I think internal combustion
engines are going to be a thing of
hobbies at racetracks you go to to drive
for fun everybody else is going to be
driving electric cars alright this is
already happening so rather than saying
let's all cut back on the amount of
driving we do because internal
combustion engines are bad for the
environment No let's say let's drive all
you want and find a better solution for
powering the car now eventually this may
all solve itself if no one even owns a
car and you know some predictions are
that that that all cars will be like
ubers you know just people ride-sharing
and Harley when anyone will drive owned
a car okay maybe that's another solution
I don't know you seem to be pointing to
the PI so the PI staying in zero-sum
territory is yes potentially looking
look like an elitist doing whatever they
want with however many things they want
and telling other people to not purchase
those things they're not strive to
materialistic ownership at the same time
we agreed on a positive some PI yes
everything is able to be better for as
many people as possible the degrees of
freedom that are opening up around the
planet for people to endeavor into
whatever they find most meaning in
pursuing is a beautiful thing to be able
to have electricity to be able to have
that to have enough nutrition to be able
to survive and be able to pursue what
you put what you find most meaningful
extremely important at the same time
that the of the recognition at least for
people that are birthed into the world
of understanding that all of the
different things that they have that
that they're given they're given life on
this planet that in itself is such a
beautiful thing first and foremost are
we really as I see it seems as to all of
the ancient traditions are pointing to
the same thing that they're pointing
towards our disconnection
from the planet that sustains us and
that our lack of understanding that is
why we have both a hyper functional
society in many ways like we agree on
but also the dysfunctional aspects of it
are due to that hmm yeah here I think I
might turn to the study of positive
psychology happiness and meaningfulness
so these are two different things
you know what makes people happy what
makes them feel like they have a
meaningful life and you know for a while
there was this being going around that
you know money doesn't make people
happier well that's easy to say if you
have a lot of money because you have
your needs met try telling that to the
you know half the population that you
know is below thirty thousand a year or
whatever the the cutoff is you know we
now know from better studies that
actually having more money does make
life better and that makes you happier
you just it gives more degrees of
freedom you know if I have more money I
don't have to worry about a budget and I
can go out to dinner anytime I want I
can buy my kids whatever toys I want we
can take trips whenever we want I don't
have to worry about it that actually is
liberating and so making having more
money is good in that respect that said
you don't have to have that because in
terms of what makes life meaningful none
of those things that I just described
except for maybe your raising your
children or something but it that
doesn't have to do with the amount of
toys they have to lead a purposeful
meaningful life it has to do with
challenges and and meaningful work
purposeful work family love
relationships and the more spiritual
things you might describe them so here's
how I say it I teach a class at Chapman
to freshmen these are first-year
students right out of high school so I
give them a whole basically skepticism
one on one how to think but I also teach
them how to think about happiness and
and meaningfulness I tell them go out
and make all the money you want money's
great that's fine but in the long run
that's not really where it's at yeah I
mean you can lead a perfectly meaningful
happy life without making a lot of money
and there's a lot of people that do that
that is all subjective right
and the so the movement toward making
people aware of you can have a
purposeful life without all the
trappings I don't want to tell people
you can't have the trappings have all
the crap you want but really in the long
run you can do it or not
and you end up over here you can give
all of that up and still have a
meaningful life and that's okay too so
really I'm a big I'm a big freedom guy
you know do whatever you want just you
know don't just don't tell me what I can
do and you do what you you do your thing
I'll do my thing but but it's worth
making people aware of you can do all
that without any material things there's
plenty of people that live at a say
middle-income or something and they're
perfectly happy and they lead meaningful
lives that's okay too and potentially
even some of the most most connected
humans to what sustains us are the ones
that are not pursuing material wealth
pursuing spiritual wealth and abundance
in that sense now I want to I want to
we've touched on this in the first time
that we sat down together it's this idea
that you want to be just skeptical
enough to make sure that all these
falsehoods are not coming into your
knowledge base in essence while
simultaneously giving enough room to
certain theories that you can then go
and hypothesize about improve in that
way you can gain new knowledge as you do
prove those things out so it seems as
though one of the things that is
probably really important to give a
little bit of room to is spirituality
with science so if science lets
spirituality kind of push the edge of
knowledge a little bit and then we make
this hypothesis right something like the
earth is alive the earth is an alive
ecosystem that is kind of having an
allergic reaction to the humans right
now something like that let's say
metaphorically metaphorically speaking
but then we scientifically probe it
right with like okay the parts per
million of co2 are now not 300 but four
over four hundred then we look at some
of the ocean areas that are acidified
and maybe look at some of the glacial
melt systems right there's a lot of
variables to take
again even solar flare intensities all
these types of things is very hard to
calculate these things but once you
start like giving spirituality a little
bit of space and then you poke it
scientifically well how do you how do
you how can we best do that style of a
process I think I think maybe what
you've described is not really part of
science but kind of the social aspects
of science or the metaphysics of science
or the spirituality of science you know
the soul in science that's all part of
it for sure science isn't everything you
know I don't know what you want to call
that part any other like car looks on
his soul of science yeah yeah yeah I
wrote up a little booklet called the
soul of science and or was it science in
the soul no I think it was the soul of
science because Dawkins wrote a book on
this - now I'm confusing his title with
mine anyway the point is is that you
know there there are how you interpret
the results and again I know you know I
like metaphors but I don't want us to
take them too seriously you know the
earth is alive and it's allergic to
humans you know it's I think the earth
doesn't care whether we're here or not
and I don't think it would make much
difference in a million years you know
whatever we do it's gonna come bounding
back I mean look what happened after you
think it's a divine accident that humans
and not divine it's it's just an actual
it's not just an axis there's no
divinity that in other words I'm with
Gould on this you know rewind the tape
and tweak the variables a little bit we
wouldn't be here now he didn't come
right now some people argue that there's
a certain amount of directionality in
evolution that's something like a
bipedal primate with tools and a big
brain on one end and the waste disposal
system at the other end and so on
there's only so many ways to structure a
land creature that it that that that
that would have a rote arisen anyway I'm
not sure about that I'm a little
skeptical of that Bob Bob Wright makes
this argument in nonzero that in his
book nonzero that there's a there's a
slight advantage to nonzero plane
organisms versus zeros playing organisms
and though
former out-compete the ladder just
slightly and that leads to
cooperativeness altruism love and things
like that okay that has happened if we
find life on another planet that would
be a second experiment did it happen
that way there and then the more we find
other planets with living organisms we
can then run that see that experiment
how it played out and simulate our own
our simulation simulator oh right yeah
so but either way I think clearly it's
clear we do play some kind of a role and
so it's not really fair to say in the
million years or won't matter what we've
done cuz it'll all come back back if we
even if we nuke ourselves I mean
Nagasaki and Hiroshima if you go there
now
you would never know except where they
left a building left from 1945 just to
remind people they came bounding back
actually within weeks they were you know
rebuilding the city and so on if you
looked at at the photographs in 1945 of
what Europe look like particularly most
of the cities in Germany just rubble you
go to any of those cities now you would
never know this happen other than they
kept that kind of awful 70s architects
60s and 70s architecture but other than
that you know they're thriving cities so
I mean things come back much faster than
we think and you know after the the
meteor strike 65 million years ago you
know that wiped out most of life on
Earth but still here is you know just it
bounced right back so I think which we
also only really discovered within the
last couple of decades
yes something that actually happened
yeah which again we're so we have so
much amnesia to understanding how we
actually got here and so to be able to
go and like have the proper archaeology
the proper anthropology in order to
understand how we got to this point it's
so important but is it really just an
accident of evolution that we're here
yeah I think so
I don't think there's anything I mean
okay look look we only have an N of one
so you know you and I and everybody
we're just talking through our hats okay
if we you know in a hundred years from
now we come back we're chronically
frozen we come back a thousand years
from now or whatever we have this
conversation and it turns out we have
now you know an an of you know six
hundred and fifty seven
inhabited planets with intelligent life
and so on and we see oh wow this is a
certain inevitability to evolution it
leads toward intelligence okay then then
that then my accident hypothesis is
probably wrong but does it also
potentially give room for some for a
soul to come through in the body into
the world and so I'm being see this
these are the hard questions very tough
things so that could be then like a very
Occam's razor
ESCA probe let me point out that
consciousness just comes directly
conscious but it could consciousness is
the sentience consciousness so sentience
either just that's better than soul so
said yes yes so we'll go with this idea
of just sentience emerging from a
complex biological phenomenon that has
occurred between from the earth to
humans reproducing and when I'm born
through my ancestors that I am birth
with sentient because of a complex
biological process of yes I think that's
probably very common in the universe I
suspect sentience probably is because it
kind it comes on pretty early demand how
you define it you know the living all
living organisms are sentient in the
sense they respond to their environment
they've taken information they processed
the information they respond accordingly
at some point if you want to throw in
self-awareness then then that reduces
the the end by quite a bit but they're
still I think my dog is self-aware in a
certain level less than say a chimp less
than a human but you know that so anyway
I think that once you get complex life
rolling than something like sentience
consciousness will arise you know just
it's just being aware of your
environment and responding to it in a
general sense that that is probably
pretty common it's something like a
spirit is not again these words or words
you use what do you mean by spirit see
but okay I'm responding and assuming
that you're using the word the way the
traditional theist
uses the word you know in a dualistic
Cartesian way that there's something
beyond the physical body so well I'm
skeptical of that I'm
you know I don't think there's anything
such such thing as mind that floats
above the brain it's not you know
there's the the neurons with their
synapses and the neural networks all
connected but that what the theist
thinks is that you know that the soul
like upon death floats off the the brain
and goes off into the ether or the
quantum field state or whatever where
did we all come from Big Bang so did we
all come from a place of unity do we all
come from one source well that's it yeah
the singularity that banged yes okay so
if we all come from that one source is
that could we then absque Ribe
potentially the word god to all that is
metaphorically I guess you could okay
but again the average theist Christian
is not thinking clearly into the Big
Bang either all sentience be the nerve
endings of God okay now you're saying
now you're sounding like Deepak Chopra
or I don't know what you think you've
been spending too much time with these
these gurus and these psychedelic varies
they're not psychedelic okay they're not
yes it's just ancient wisdom Asian
wisdom and you know I also come from a
very deep science
yes I'm wrongdoing yet simple
disciplines so to be one that can kind
of you know play with both and try and
see what edges of knowledge can be
pushed what things we can remember case
I love take your friend the Ray Kurzweil
you know is you know is there a God not
yet but we're working on that
you know the singularity of you know
this super advanced AI would be godlike
that's true again the average person
thinks of God as this personal being
that brought the universe into into
being it created us knows about us cares
about us and is creating a an afterlife
for us okay I don't think that's what
you're talking about and I think that's
actually a pretty strong argument for
God I think it is I think God just being
all that is from the Big Bang until now
an earthly potentially not being just an
accident of biological evolution but
really something that's profoundly
beautiful that has evolved humans that
are able to figure out they're supposed
to remember
in a sense that we all come from the
same place and that nature sustains us
and that we have to work together across
this planet and that when we forget that
it makes space for some of the the the
the corruptive aspects of our okay does
that that's maybe more of a straw a
steel man argument on the point of view
maybe Auden well I mean Sagan famously
said you know he humans or brains or
consciousness as a way of the cosmos to
know itself you know because we are
Stardust you know we're just the the
product of stars that went supernova you
know we are carbon and so on and okay so
if that's what you're after yes I can
see that as a kind of a metaphor
although it's literally true we are the
way for the cosmos to know itself yes
but I don't want to impune that cosmos
with agency like it's a thing that is it
itself is aware we are the cosmos is
eyes and ears mmm in that sense yeah
yeah so now beautiful though the
perception of the Big Bang of all that
is is now in the sentient life-forms
that are perceiving and experiencing
this beautiful experiment that were that
we're in so but see that right there
science right we can link something like
like Sagan talking about the cosmos
observing experiencing yourself was
something that spirituality has also
been talking about about how we're all
children of the cosmos coming through
this experience so I think by being able
to merge that science of spirituality
right there it can actually do really
beautiful justice for us understanding
why we're here yeah well if it motivates
people to act in a in a more healthy way
but for themselves personally and
socially okay that's fine I mean that is
kind of the role of myth and metaphor
and literature is to motivate people is
to reflect something about the world not
in a scientific way but in another way
that then motivates people
moves them emotionally and this is that
this discussion that I've had with
Jordan Peterson who you know he's a big
myth guy and the importance of myths and
stories in human society and personal
lives you yeah yeah and I think he's
right about that you know now and
there's a body of literature now in
evolutionary psych on evolutionary
literature you know to what extent do
stories actually reflect the true nature
of human nature for example in other
words the novelists had this figured out
before the scientist did you know they
just by observation just by looking
around and having life experiences they
realize there's certain themes that come
up over and over and over in literature
and that's because they're real they're
reflecting something that's real in
human nature you know love relationships
power deception and you know the better
angels and the inner demons you know
that all those characteristics we study
scientifically they're there and all the
novels centuries ago because they're
true in this sense so that to that I'm
willing to grant religion myths you know
that sort of Joseph Campbell preached
orden Peters and Joseph Campbell's you
know kind of looking for the
commonalities amongst world myths either
they got there through diffusion
cultural diffusion or they are
reinventing the same ideas because it's
reflecting something underlying reality
in these myths that that cover such
important aspects of the human
experience are also ones that indigenous
elders are also mentioning with regard
to where we all come from and what
sustains us and so by being able to
piece these things together I think it
does help us behave in a more healthy
and sustainable way moving forward some
of the things that we maybe are
currently deceiving us so when we come
into the world do we come with a purpose
do we come with something that we know
is going to bring us the most meaning
and then it's our responsibility to
figure out you know that is I think so
okay yeah I do think so I mean again
social scientists that study this you
know come up with certain things that
are true for most people most of the
time again having meaningful work having
family you don't have to be married but
having some kind of loving relationship
with another human being
you know having children you know I've
been doing something that takes you out
of yourself you work for a non-profit
you belong to a church you volunteer on
the weekends you do something with a
community of people to some common cause
you know that that leads to spirituality
some people get it you know do
meditation or they do long walks on the
beach you know or they go to church you
know there's nothing there's more
there's lots of ways to get it no one
group has a monopoly on that clearly
this is more than what science is
offering by itself but science can study
and go look these are the things that
the happiest people do you know just
like in the same way that longevity
researchers you know look for the the
you know the blue zones that the places
where people live the longest you know
they eat fish or the Mediterranean diet
or whatever but one of the
characteristics is is a community that's
you know social community where you have
friends and people that care about you
that you care about relationships
that kind of thing and so they're I
think to the extent that the ancient
wisdoms or religions or myths have
talked about that they probably figured
that out through trial and error and
observation I think it's important to
make a point because you keep bringing
up you know these wisdom elders and so
on you know a lot of them came up with
crazy ideas that turned out to be just
utter nonsense and we should recognize
that just because someone is an ancient
elder doesn't mean the right they could
be just completely off the rails so
again you have to check the ideas with
reality so I mean there was a slew of
books in the 70s and 80s you know that
dancing movie masters the DAO of physics
the turning point you know friedhof
Capra I read all those books I loved
them great stuff you know the kind of
marriage of Western science with Eastern
tradition and you know some of it turned
out to be you know okay could there's a
match there others that's a bunch of
nonsense there's no
link there and so it depends if we can't
just say just because it's old it's true
yeah because you we can easily be
deceived by people that are carrying
something that that is that could
potentially you know be deceiving us and
that's that's a very bad as well yet we
can also like a long walk on the beach
can be different for someone that is
deeply connecting to the ocean and the
origins of our life that is so much
different than someone that comes to the
beach takes a selfie of themselves and
starts posting it on the Internet and so
these are completely different ways of
perceiving the world
there's a reason beachfront property is
so much more expensive than inland
property or if you're inland having you
know a spectacular mountain view or
being up on a cliff overlooking a valley
those homes are more expensive there's
and this is not just some random quirk
of real estate I mean the location
location location is defined by a very
certain characteristic site that I think
does tap into human nature ed Wilson
calls us Biophilia we love nature and we
love the biosphere and you know acacia
trees bodies of water crashing waves
sand you know cliffs and you know
looking down and now there's much debate
in evolutionary psychology about why
that is or even if it is because there's
criticisms about about that you know
like certain landscape paintings are
rated higher than other kinds of
paintings and yet some of the most
revered art work has nothing to do with
nature or anything like that
so ma'amed it's a debated point whether
it's an adaptation or it's just a
byproduct Steve Pinker calls his
cheesecake you know like certain kinds
of art maybe just cheesecake it's just
it just tastes good for some other
reason not having to do with that
particular thing anyway but the point no
deeper point is that we do which are
after here this kind of spirituality
connected to the earth whether there's
evolved adaptive reasons for that or not
clearly it's something in our nature
oh yeah yeah we care about against the
science now to where people are walking
out into force and now we're calling it
forced therapy that cortisol levels
decrease when you oh yes force just
things like this hug a tree come on I
mean do we really need to be probing
this so much with science to actually
finally understand that me going out
into nature
will help me decrease my stress levels
it's pretty damn obvious yes and then
the way that you behave there are you
going there just to take a selfie and
immediately start posting it right going
there to actually connect to the essence
of our origins completely different take
on it
um I don't face your cellphone into the
forest there's II yes yes there's
there's this take oh do go a day without
using the technologies and see how you
feel after it doesn't feel good for the
first day I've done this so after about
day two or so then the anxiety starts to
come down and after like day four you're
like I didn't really need that phone
life is pretty damn good with that I was
pretty good about it yeah yeah yeah and
in thinking how much more focus do you
have on getting things done that you
want to do but then again also if you
were offline for a week during the time
that I just figured out a couple days
ago that I was coming down here we would
have been able to coordinate write this
happen so the Jews with this soffit with
the Sabbath yes okay not just the Jews
but you know they're the ones that make
the biggest deal about it you know
midnight or sundown Friday to sundown
Saturday you know some of my atheist
friends make fun of religious rituals
but really some of them have some
grounding that you know it's a it's a
way of carving out a niche of of time
for you and your family and nothing else
and that's good yeah that's good and
once made fun of the Mormons wearing the
the secret underwear right and in the
audience was a Mormon woman who said
well okay dr. Sherman come on that's not
very it's not I don't really secretly
think the underwear is doing something
too you know
it's just a way of my honoring the
tradition or my paying respect to you
know the authority of the church or
something like that and I I forget her
exact words but I changed my mind about
that I thought
okay I see that I get that okay let's
let's let's tackle this one so there's a
we gave this example earlier I think
it's a really good one to kind of start
things off with this idea of humans just
have a deep amount of amnesia happening
with like our origin story because again
a couple decades ago we weren't sure
that the that the extinction event of
the dinosaur era was due to asteroid
impact and now we know that and it makes
way more sense that that made space for
the humans to evolve you know very
similarly we can start thinking about
these things of things like a little
black light at bay you know the the site
that you were talking about with Graham
Hancock and I think these are actually
very profound archaeological discoveries
of us that holy cow how many ancient
sites are buried in our planet that are
slowly like disappearing but that we
need to go and find to piece together
our story of how we got here and I do
think and I'm interested to hear your
thoughts about this I do think there are
gatekeepers I think there are
gatekeepers that prevent us from
advancing certain aspects of not only
our origin story but even more about
things like lobbies there's lobbies in
the PAS lobbyists in the pockets of
different governments around the planet
that are that are pushing their own
personal agendas around pharmaceuticals
or around fake foods and fake physicians
and fake politicians and that so so
these types of things and their
gatekeepers that are approved that have
literally set up different styles of
defenses that are preventing the the
truth it's being done skating in a sense
what are your thoughts of me yeah well
in the first point I think Graham is
correct there's a lot of these sites
that are clear that people didn't live
there they went there to do something
and it was probably was something like a
spiritual religious whatever that word
would have meant to them 10,000 years
ago say something like that Gobekli Tepe
may be you know my archaeo-astronomer
gary
at the Griffith Observatory his name
escapes me now think of it in a minute
you know he talks about the a lot of
these archeoastronomy sites as they are
kind of spiritual sites where you go to
kind of pay respect to the cosmos that
kind of thing and we've kind of lost
that yeah yeah he makes a point that he
has tells a funny story that there was a
blackout in Los Angeles you know one
night I think was in 1986 or something
and the next day the observatory got in
Griffith Observatory got all these calls
like there was something weird about
this guy it's like yeah you could see
the stars oh I need more that yes yes I
think but I in terms of this amnesia I
do think that this proliferation of
channels and science shows has trickled
down to where everybody now knows about
the Big Bang and the theory of evolution
and the inner halls and this and that
and you know science popularizers are
they're everywhere now and there's a lot
of great material and the CGI is so good
on these shows now you know the new
cosmos reboot but but they all have
fantastic CGI you know what does a black
hole look like you know and and in that
seer in that film interstellar you know
they consulted Kip Thorne and he gave
them the equations that this is how out
of portray a black hole so what you see
is when a black hole would actually look
like and and it's so real particularly
in a theater I mean you can almost
viscerally feel what it would be like to
be near a black hole so I think that's
helped in terms of you know like Carl
said Sagan said about cosmos it is our
story it is an origin story it's a myth
but it has the benefit of actually also
being true
you know most religious myths maybe
they're true maybe they're not who knows
there's no mechanism to test it and that
wasn't the purpose anyway of the story
but for the modern scientific origins
story it's also true which makes to me
makes it even more meaningful so when I
go I visit observatories I like to go
inside those huge domes
you know like mal Wilson up above Los
Angeles go down to Mount Palomar with
the 200 in
I've been to a bunch of them and to me
it's like on a church and I've been to
the big cathedrals in Europe the
Chartres Cathedral the big dome in in
Cologne and my wife is from oh it's it I
can really feel the emotional
spirituality that believers get even
though I'm an atheist because those
those structures are so impressive they
are so huge and I can see you know let's
say 500 years ago and that was the
biggest thing anyone will ever see in
their life they transcend people's egos
working in cooperation to make these
beautiful Center centuries long work
projects yes and I used to think that it
would just be four thousand five
thousand years ago that we were
constructing pyramids and that this is
something that is okay fine like it was
just that many millennia ago that humans
could do that and then we doubled the
time period because go Blakely tap is
just one example now of being able to
move these monolithic there's pieces of
stone into this spiritual location
you're hypothesizing right now right now
that we think that people went there but
to be able to add you know a serious
5,000 year chunk on to human history and
say now we were doing that 5,000 years
before that plus being able to say okay
we had a designated site where people
were worshipping in a sense and then we
can hypothesize about this but that they
were connecting with the cosmos they're
connecting with what had given them life
and that they were here and now today it
seems like we are so much in the
metropolis is so disconnected with light
pollution from our cosmos so
disconnected from when we take a sip of
water to actually be truly grateful for
that nourishment that we're receiving it
feels like we're wildly in a sense this
to pinker argument true in so many
regards but in terms of spiritual wisdom
Pinker's argument may actually fail in
that respect that we our ancestors may
have had the edge of knowledge and
spirituality just been pushed way
further out in turn especially spiritual
science compete look at the beautiful
structures that were left behind versus
now our spiritual science seems like
it's we're still scraping pieces
together like at like
actual edge of knowledge has rescinded
actually over time what do you think
about that mmm well that goes a little
too far baby because I don't think
that's what Pinker is talking about he's
talking about something of course yeah
but I mean he's the overall trajectory
of the words that he said the story that
he's saying and that you see in the
moral arc and whatnot yeah is true in so
many regards but I think to say it's a
scientific consensus that this is the
best time to be lied in so yeah well
there's possibly actually one little
aspect of it let's say for now
that spiritual connection today when
you're birthed into a metropolis is much
more difficult to achieve than when
you're born into a part of the world
that doesn't have light pollution we are
connected to growing off the land these
types of things you're walking into a
supermarket you don't even know where
the farmers are versus when you actually
go to a farmer's market you can ask
where is your farm can I convince on
your forum big difference I see where I
see where you're going with this and and
there's some truth to that in as much as
say hunter-gatherers we're taller
healthier had fewer cavities their bones
were stronger they had less arthritis
than farmers a few thousand years after
the Agricultural Revolution so it was
healthier to live in a hunter-gatherer
environment and certainly Jared Diamond
makes this point in his book the year
before no the world before yesterday I
think it's called and he talks about you
know the connectedness that everybody
and a hunter-gatherer group has with
each other they care about each other
they know each other and they resolve
disputes they just sit in the in the
quad area and they have it at hash it
out and they apologize
preparations are made life goes on and
all that that's true but you know we
don't have that world that world's never
coming back you know and and so the
moving forward can we recapture some of
the positive aspects of that let's get
rid of the communicable diseases that
killed almost everybody that lived by
the time they were 40 or 50 and we get
to live longer can we have the benefits
of modern medicine and the spiritual
aspects yes we can and I think there's
enough movements I've been to the ehsan
Institute several times you know that
kind of
what did they call it personal personal
growth movement something like that I
forget what they call it but you know
just getting in touch with the things
that matter I think that helps religion
is one way to do it is a reminder once a
week I mean that's why do people go to
church they don't go to hear a lecture
about that you know the five proofs of
God by Thomas Aquinas or you know what
was there before the Big Bang type they
want it they want it to be you know to
hang out with their friends and fellow
community members that think like them
you know we all need that and so but we
can you can get that now in the modern
world there's a you know maybe Facebook
hangout pages are not the quite the
right way for everybody I know a lot of
Millennials are into that but not
millenials II generation Z hygienist not
my thing but but I get it hanging out
with my friends our family and anyway I
think I think there's lots of ways to
get that
and we shouldn't but but I don't want to
idealize the past I mean life was really
was nasty brutish and short for most
people and you know if you go back to
you know people long for the live in the
Middle Ages or before the modern period
or something like that
they're envisioning their the King in
the castle when they have all the
goodies you know 99.9% of the world
lived in abject poverty you know no
you'd be living in a mud hut you'd be
dead in no time no running water no
toilets no toilet paper you know no
dentistry you know the food was
basically just this bland gruel that and
you don't know if you're gonna have it
tomorrow your life today is really
better than most of that ya world it's
so to not forget exactly what you just
described meanwhile simultaneously
revisiting past time periods where
humans may have had certain aspects of
their life structured in a way that is
quite nice and so that essence so to be
able to maybe balance some of that those
things of how humans could work together
to do things how humans could have them
potentially more time that was less
distracted more wholefoods at times all
these different types of aspects less
fake foods fake politicians fake
physicians all this stuff
that is so the amount of maybe like self
dealing and other aspects of our Family
Values not scaling over time are slowly
looks like changing as we decentralize a
lot of the technologists revisit this
one aspect of it which is okay within
the the the within gatekeepers I'm just
gonna keep yeah within DQ yeah we're
we're cuz I agree with I feel like we
agree that that there's like you just
described earlier that there do the
democratization of being able to spread
truth science this type of thing is
actually really really helpful and it's
awakening more people um super true at
the same time it's with corporations
with with certain groups that it seems
as though are setting up purposely
obstacles that make it more and more
difficult to try and say hey is it
possible that our origins are actually
different than what we say they are or
is it possible that there are all agha
Polly dynamics yeah happening yeah
corporation there are gatekeepers for
sure in business and in science there's
a reason for the gatekeepers in a way
science is conservative and you have to
kind of jump through the hoops and get
the union card your go to graduate
school get your degree work with a
mentor and so on there's those reasons
those are in place and the reason is
because most of us are wrong about most
of the things we think about most of the
time so there has to be some kind of
filter to you know to kind of make sure
you don't go off the rails down some
path that we've already gone down and
found out wasn't the wrong line of
research so I'm gonna guide you this way
now the drawback to that of course is
you may miss some of the creativity of
somebody fresh new into the field and
yet science does come up with new stuff
all the time so somehow or another new
ideas are not kept out by the
gatekeepers the gatekeeper the
gatekeeping process works pretty well
for filtering out fraud pseudoscience
bad science it's not perfect but but it
catches enough of the bad stuff and it
still lets through enough
the new creative ideas that things march
along pretty well maybe not as fast as
we would like something like the FDA is
maybe their filter is too tight and
maybe you want to go to a European
system where new drugs can come on the
market a little faster same problem you
know the gatekeeper thing but if you had
no geek gatekeepers then we'd have you
know the quacks on this street corner
selling you you know every quack remedy
for everything and you know people would
would not benefit from that so we got to
have something like that now people like
back to Graham Hancock who I like very
much
he's definitely an outsider you know
he's not an archaeologist because no
training but he knows a lot I mean you
know he's traveled into he's a bit of
multi-sites
yeah and his point about the gatekeeping
is that the gatekeepers kind of keep him
out I'm not sure that's actually true I
mean he's probably sold more books than
all other archaeologists combined ever
so it's like well Graham you're not
exactly unknown you're probably the most
famous archaeologist living today who's
not actually an archaeologist so so the
gatekeepers may keep you out of the peer
review journals but he's not even
submitting work to them anyway so his
and his he gets on Joe Rogan pretty much
whenever he wants and he has you know 20
million views of his various appearances
there so it's not like there's no voice
for people like Graham Hancock there is
it the problem that he's encountering is
that like we call this anomaly hunting
so he's really good at plucking out
anomalies that don't seem to fit the
mainstream theory like Clovis first you
know okay so what did the first humans
come to America 11,000 years ago okay
well that appears to be a little on the
short side maybe it's 13 15 maybe up to
20,000 years ago depending on this site
that's I you know Mesa that Mesa Verde
anyway it's escaping me at the moment
and there's a few others and some grand
points to those ago you see the old
guards the gatekeepers you know they did
not allow in those older dates well
actually yes they did
because now we know about
those older dates the problem when you
then jump to like a hundred and thirty
thousand years ago in reference to that
fine in San Diego of the mammoth bones
now that's an interesting study because
that was innate published in nature your
review journal by a real archaeologist
you know not some alternative guy okay
what do we do with that okay we don't
have to do anything with it let science
carry it out and let other people look
at the bones and so on there's since
been a paper published being skeptical
of that but if there were humans here a
hundred and thirty thousand years ago
and then the next date to that is like
say nineteen twenty thousand years ago
there should be hundreds thousands
millions of fossils and tools and bones
and various things to fill in that gap
so in time in the course of the next few
years or decades either that gap will be
filled or it'll turn out this was an
incorrect anomaly that the it was
actually the bones were broken by the
construction project trucks and whatnot
not people 130,000 years ago that's
probably gonna be the explanation but
okay so that's very hubristic I think
because I think that there's so much
that is still undiscovered
in how we got here that's maybe maybe
but okay so that but that's kind of like
a negative evidence argument that that
because you can't disprove it at the
moment
therefore this theory is is viable no
how about it's a karl popper's
conjecture and refutation conjecture all
you want but we're gonna try to refute
it and if you can't fill in those gaps
which over time will likely happen maybe
just waving our techniques are gonna get
better
that's why gobekli tepe and so many of
the other ancient sites around the world
it's just like slow down our tools are
gonna get better we're gonna be able to
really do things like you can actually
use interesting of radar techniques in
order to identify some of the areas in
the Amazon or Sahara or continental
shelf these are very interesting ways of
using technology to better understand
our origin story but what about within
the core what about within the
other spaces of our world like within
let's take other examples like the
oligopoly dynamics that may be at play
with technology companies or with food
companies or with all of the different
things that just seem like we don't
actually the truth is being opt you
skated purposefully in order for us to
not understand what actually is healthy
food or what is healthy use of
technology all these types of things yes
well how do we know about that
because of whistleblowers and outsiders
like Gary Taubes and Nina ty Colts
writing books about the food industry
not just them others have exposed what
the chemical and food industry has done
over the last 50 years well so so in a
way it is what we mean by science is
self-correcting but you have to have a
free press you know open inquiry lots of
alternative places to publish and get
your voices heard you know Gary Taubes
has been touting this you know the sugar
and and good calories bad calories since
the 90s and you know he was considered a
nut job and an outsider at the time
pushing against the pyramid food food
pyramid consensus and it's looking like
he was right now so I'm the I'm the
gatekeeper thing it's like yeah that see
the gatekeeping didn't work didn't it
work I mean now we all know about this
his books were published I mean it's his
first paper was published in the New
York Times Magazine that's not exactly
the gatekeepers I've kept him silent
right but how many decades hasn't taken
for the gatekeepers of certain
industries to continue well the ship
turned slowly
the Titanic is moving too slow with the
iceberg cut okay it feels like that and
they need to be identified the
gatekeeper lobbyists well I think the
names you know Naomi Oreskes and her
co-author I forget his name of the
merchants of doubt' they name names in
there you know that they named the
tobacco lobbyists who were hired by the
chemical industry who were hired by the
climate it companies to do the same
people to plant Dow
have seed if you can do tobacco you can
do flame retardants and in global
warming and so on I think it's not a
secret we know which companies you know
that ExxonMobil and the Koch brothers we
know who's funding these things so they
are part of the gatekeepers but we're
the gatekeepers keepers if we were you
know we're watching the keepers that's
why you absolutely have to have a free
press yes our cooperative processes in
order to identify those and build things
that obsolete those old systems is so
critical and then another example is
just that when you take something like
things that again things that we use
every single day these these
extraordinary pieces of technology that
are actually being that have you do
psychometric profiles of two billion
human beings that are then waiting at
you all the time watching everything
that you do to make it irresistible for
you to get off of the device because the
business models are tied to the time on
screen of you watching advertisements
are looking at them in the feeds so
again these things can we point out
who's in charge can we point these
things out can we say that we need to
make it easier again things like why
don't you tell us about what the thing
that you were just mentioned with the
importance of some freedom of press and
freedom of enterprise things that enable
us to actually have new perspectives be
brought in and then obsolete those old
systems because this is something else
that you're really proud yeah
well you want to name names at Mark
Zuckerberg okay there we go
mr. Zuckerberg what are you doing
remember that moment in his
congressional hearing what congressman
how do you make money senator we sell
ads but it's free we sell the data oh
he's like everybody in tech of course
already knew all this but you know the
general pump that was what less than two
years ago that this kind of became
publicly aware and it was like
Zuckerberg do you will you tell us where
you stayed last night and it was like no
yeah like well why well you know we're
right right yeah yeah well again I think
the you know the solution of that is
push back and just awareness and the
fact that you don't have to use social
media you don't have to do it no one's
making you do it so anyway and then what
was the most overall on the freedom of
speech and freedom of freedom yeah so
again I'm a big free speech guy for free
speech open inquiry we got to have it
again because most of us are wrong about
most things most of the time and the
only way to find out is to interact with
other people as much as you can just
awareness of the fact that we all live
in these silos these bubbles these echo
chambers pick your metaphor makes I
think makes you aware that well maybe I
should talk to other people that are not
Republican or Democrat maybe I should
read the New York Times and The Wall
Street Journal and then see what other
people are saying just in case BOTS
find your blind spots and I think you
know the research on the backfire effect
is now showing that in fact you can talk
people out of their beliefs through
better arguments and evidence this can
work it's hard but the D biasing
programs can work by making people aware
of their biases or manding instead of
strong me yes exactly the kind of stuff
we're doing here so you know the
technology of course has its dark side
but this enables us to do like what
we're doing right here right now and and
there's tons of podcasts and and you
know the the studies showing the
percentage of people listening to
podcasts you know daily weekly monthly
and so on just keeps going up sky rise
more people come online - yeah and it's
great it's great so this is this is what
we're talking about with a Free Press
yes we're this is part of the press yes
you know and and so you know the
mainstream guys are having to scramble
to change their business models and so
on to keep up good that's good yeah yeah
that's good I mean people who are always
worried about you know just a handful of
half a dozen companies own all the major
media sources aren't you worried no I'm
not because you know there's all these
other platforms out there you know Joe
Rogan and I mean so they can squelch
Alex Jones okay but they're you know
it's an open market people can devise
their own platforms and start something
new yeah one of the things also that
have to also be aware of it's just that
those companies that we distribute these
these pieces of content through are able
to have their own again oligopoly
dynamics of deciding on who they can
restrict who they can't these types of
things so so that's why you know think
spot Jordans platform and all these
other things are coming yes yes see
where things move in that direction I'm
worried about people like Dave room and
preggers you videos being the censored
censored whatever they're doing D you
monetize the platform for certain venues
you know so I tweeted the other day you
know dear team YouTube I've watched
dozens of preggers you videos I agree
with about 50% of them a disagree with
about 25% and I'm undecided about the
other 25% please adjust your algorithm
so I only see the ones I agree with
thank you yeah and of course this is
ridiculous you know just let everybody
have their say I understand that their
concern you know that they were allowing
Isis people to set up yeah okay I get
that I don't want to find beheadings oh
yeah yeah yeah of course you know those
are the again this is that sort of
lifeboat ethics what do you do with this
most extreme example and the problem is
when you push toward the center where it
gets fuzzier you know this is my
innopolis a right-wing racist bigoted
whereas he is he a performance artist or
a provocateur well you know what is he
it's those fuzzy areas where I think
they err on the wrong side well we
better cut out all these people draw the
line here I think you're drawing a line
too far over here bring it back closer
to the no beheadings videos or something
that's much more obvious yes and once
you get into like well Prager you has a
video about progressive tax versus a
flat tax and come on really I mean
that's these are very debatable
questions abortion pro-choice pro-life
here's our video in favor of pro-life
that's okay
you know that's this is not a beheading
video yeah I think they draw the line
too far yes yes and I would think and
just another last point maybe to finish
up on is there's a
there's a growing amount of interest in
the idea of kind of what we were talking
about earlier around about about oneness
about how we all from the Big Bang until
now are coming from the same place and
we gave these scientific examples of
where the cosmos are observing and
experiencing themselves that these types
of ways of living on a day-to-day basis
connected to that source connected to
that this aspect of unity oneness that
we can remain skeptical of it and I
think there's a healthy amount of that
but that that can be done while
simultaneously understanding that the
almost a faster that we can understand
that we all come from the same place the
faster that we can all move towards yeah
similar I think that's what one of the
best things science does for us is it
shows us the unity of all life you know
Darwin's idea is you know we all came
from the same ancestors all of us not
just all humans came from the same pre
human species but that all living
organisms have the same DNA the same
force you know the some base pairs and
so on and so there was only one Genesis
moment on earth and it came very early
and that's a pretty amazing thing so we
are all one in that sense and if you
want to push it back to the Big Bang you
know we don't know why the laws of
nature are that the way they are and
it's balanced the way it is and so on
and but instead of going to the whether
it was a fine tune or the tuned enough
how about just say we're lucky to be in
a universe where this could even happen
where we get to be here and just be
thankful for that I totally follow on
that just being grateful for being alive
here at the same time I'm aware that so
much more
that you know Michael we are such a such
so small on the timeline so you know 25
years 50 or 75 years of life of being
able to just you know parse all
information try and input in what we
think is the best information to make us
as intelligent as possible and even then
it's such a tiny little bit of all the
information and so to you know to be
able to look back at the hundred billion
humans that built the world that we live
in or to look back at how billions of
years of evolution finally got to this
pinnacle spot of Earth where we can be
birthed and have life and be the cosmos
observing experiencing itself that it
just I I want to just know you do you
feel like it's still potentially more of
like just an evolution of sentience
rather than a divine purpose that yet I
would not use divine in in the way that
most theists use the word I think if we
if we want to say the universe is divine
because it has the laws of nature that
gives rise to sentient beings that then
become aware of the universe having
those laws of nature that give rise to
sentience is that a thumbs up if that's
a thought that if that's divinity then
I'm a believer okay so okay but then I
think we got on the same the same page
there that was a very beautiful way of
thinking of writing it because I I think
that is what the wisdoms are pointing at
is exactly what you just described okay
that that is such a blessing that we are
here and because of that if we if we
were able to understand that if every
child born into the world was able to
understand that then it would be easier
to eradicate so many of the issues that
we see in our world but because we go to
the ocean we're like selfie post on
Instagram rather than be grateful for
the fact that we get life from this this
is our life force that that disconnect
is the reason why we have so many of the
issues so that in itself this idea of
the unity this idea of all that is or
or divine purpose that we have here yeah
Michael I'm sure that like you know this
idea of skepticism around spirituality I
think is very beautiful we spent a lot
of time last time we talked on talking
about the skepticism around science as
well and also scientific advancements
that have brought us here all these
types of things so I think this has been
a really solid piecing together on a
second conversation and a very great
good you joined me welcome thanks for
coming to Santa Barbara yeah you're a
fun to talk to the people huge thank you
to everyone for tuning in we greatly
appreciate it we'd love to hear your
thoughts in the comments below
on this episode do let us know what you
think about skepticism around
spirituality around the topics that we
talked about to have more conversations
and your friends your co-workers people
online on social media your family about
spirituality about skepticism around
spirituality you have more of these
conversations around the world and also
check out the links in the bio below to
Michael's work his website Michael
Shermer COMSOL skeptic comm also the
links to the moral arc and heavens on
earth are below as well do check out the
books and everyone support the artists
entrepreneurs the organizations around
the world do you believe and support
them help them grow if you believe in us
help support us so we can continue doing
cool things like coming outside the
Santa Barbara to interview great people
like Michael all of our links are below
to our patreon our cryptocurrency link
our PayPal link support us help us grow
and go and build the future everyone
manifest your dreams into the world
thank you so much for tuning in and we
will see you soon peace
would you say we did a good job on
skepticism around spirituality wait wait
wait wait wait what you just said that
wait come back come back come back wait
come back and say that into the mic okay
okay
all right all right oh I love that
that's huge Michael the fact that you
just said that is is massive I'm very
grateful that you just said that